(gunshot)
- Oh!
(slow James Bond themed music)
- I don't like guns at all.
- I don't have a negative
opinion about guns,
I do have negative opinions about people.
- I've been invited to a gun
range before with friends,
and I've said no, and I've just
sat in the car outside of the gun range
while they shot guns.
- I'm an Eagle Scout, I
was raised in the South,
I've shot a lot of guns.
.22 rifle, 10-gauge shotgun,
12-gauge shotgun, Desert Eagle,
and another type of handgun
that I don't remember.
- Who are you?
- It was my bachelor party.
- What?
- I shot an arrow once.
- I question why as a society
we consider guns masculine.
- It's like a James Bond thing,
and he's a cool, sexy guy,
and I'm a cool, sexy guy.
- They keep talking about James Bond.
Kieth will not shut up about Texas?
- When we dress like James
Bond, it's not real somehow.
- These are military grade weapons,
whose only purpose is to kill people.
To kill a lot of people
very fast, very effectively.
- When you grow up around guns,
you know how to handle them properly.
We should be able to go to a gun range
and fire military-grade weapons.
- I'm going to go into this fresh,
thinking, what is the feeling
that I'm going to get from it?
Because maybe there is something
to masculinity and guns.
- If I get to wear a tuxedo
and shoot guns, I'm excited.
(fast typing)
- You could die here.
- What?
- I'll hook it up in here for you.
Only thing that you've
- Woah!
- got to do is cock it down.
- [Try Guy] Okay.
- [Instructor] Then close it.
- And I'm ready, this is live.
- [Instructor] That's a live round.
- Guy's I'm going to sh--
(gunshot)
Oh!
- The first blow went off and I jumped.
I was not ready for it.
There was no "ready, set, go."
- Alright, here goes nothing.
(gunshot)
- Oh, Jesus Christ!
- Assault rifles are actually
easier to shoot than handguns.
There's hardly any kick
because it goes so fast.
- Woo!
(gunshot)
- It's easy to forget why you're there,
that the purpose of these
guns is to kill people,
and each time you're pulling the trigger,
that's another life you could be taking.
- I'm Keith! How you doing?
- It gives you this real adrenaline
that took me hours to come down from.
- I think my body went on a high--
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] and I just
completely turned into this
very primitive, basic creature.
- [Voiceover] When you just
repeat shoot like that,
you're almost afraid of yourself.
- [Voiceover] Me taking the safety off,
could've killed someone.
- Oh!
- Can I just get a hug?
Can I just get a hug real quick?
(fast typing)
- Does my cheekbone really have
to be that close to the gun?
- No, not too close.
- And it's not going to hurt my cheek?
- No, Lean your body forward.
- Okay.
(gunshot)
- Oh, mother of God!
This (beep) became like an adult toy.
Guns are not toys.
- Oh, every time it's
punching me in the arm.
Now that I've done it, I
get it, it's exhilarating.
- Oh, I feel that power!
It's like I'm turning into an animal.
I'm going to try and shoot
this guy in the nuts.
Who does that?
- Woo!
- I killed him!
How many times am I shooting this?
All I could think of
while I was shooting is,
"Aw man, I hope I'm out of bullets."
(fast typing)
- Probably the biggest
- Damn
revolver that's commercially made.
- Whoever gets the closest to the red dot
will not have to pay for dinner.
- It's like playing a
round of golf with weapons.
- Exactly.
- If you feel the recoil
is too much for you,
let it go over your head.
Do not fight it, because
it will come back.
- So you can punch yourself in the face?
- Yeah, don't do that.
- Wow, it is heavy.
- Who do you think will be the
worst, from what you've seen?
(laughing)
(gunshot)
- Oh, holy (beep).
- Ahhhhh!
(gunshot)
- Ah!
(Jeers)
- Ah, that was terrifying!
- [Voiceover] Keith wins.
- I'm really glad I did it.
I've not done it so many
times because I was afraid,
but I faced my fear, and
I think it's totally fine
to shoot any kind of gun in a gun range,
because that's the place you go.
You play golf on a golf course,
you shoot guns in a gun range.
- The first thing I said
when I held the gun was,
was I turned and then I
said, "Take a photo of me."
And all I can think of is I'm desperately
trying to compensate for something.
- I get it, I now get it.
I didn't get it, and now I get it.
Guns are really (beep) fun.
- It changed me.
I don't think that I'm as
pro-gun as I used to be.
- In terms of actually feeling more manly
from shooting a gun...
I don't think I'm more of a man.
- The experience didn't turn us into men,
it turned us into boys.
- I might have kids one day.
There's no way that my kids
are responsible gun owners.
An accident is bound to happen.
- The men, or the people at the gun range,
who really knew what they were doing,
I respect that.
- I guess my takeaway today
is that the whole thing
is a little more complicated.
I see why people like it.
It doesn't necessarily
change the way I think,
but it does shade it in a little bit.
- For the record, for me personally,
eating pizza is still
more of a genuine thrill
than shooting a gun.
- Yeah, this is pretty good.
And, it's quite a kick.
(laughter)